[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 78
jusqu'au 13 juillet la rédaction de
TVfil vous donne rendez-vous en direct à
partir de 18h pour faire le point sur
l'actualité du département et ce soir
avec nos invités il sera notamment
question de la fibre optique bonsoir
Maxime bonsoir Fri et ce soir on parlera
fibre optique avec vous alors tout à
fait on parlera de fibre optique et
notamment de l'arrêt de la régie cantiop
sur saquentin ce qui enura des
conséquences pour les usagers et bien
tout à fait les conséquences pour
l'instant c'est que ce sont les
opérateurs privés pour ne pas les citer
Orange et SFR qui vont prendre le relais
en tout cas c'est ce qui est prévu pour
l'instant à noter quand même que cantiop
continue de développer de déployer la
fibre optique pour les entreprises on
fera le point sur ce dossier dans
quelques minutes comme chaque lundi le
point également complet sur le sport
avec Adrien citôt bonsoir Adrien j- 25
avant l'ouverture des j de Londres et
oui et Jeux Olympiques avec gymnastique
ça tombe bien puisque nous recevrons le
club d'lancour morpa et nous parlerons
de Camille coudr qui va peut-être
décrocher sa qualification dans les
jours à venir également du tennis
puisque la saison est terminée et le
club de plaisir réussit l'exploit
d'avoir une équipe masculine en
Nationale 1 et une féminine en Nationale
1 également et de plus l'équipe B
masculine se tient en Nationale 3 ça
fait beaucoup de national tout ça on
fera effectivement le point pour que ce
soit bien clair dans une quinzaine de
minutes ce de juillet l'actualité c'est
aussi le festival mémoire d'étoile qui
se poursuit le festival de cinéma de
boisarcy qui fête sa 11e édition ses
organisateurs nous en diront plus vous
découvrirez également les images de
laavenue de Jean-Michel RIB dimanche
soir pour la projection de son film Méo
muséba pour débuter la citation du jour
elle est signée Henry Guenot aujourd'hui
le nouveau député UMP de la 3e
circonscription des ivelines interrogé
sur franceino ce matin à propos du
dernier ouvrage de Roseline Bachelot
l'ancienne plume de Nicolas sarcoszi a
déclaré les auteurs ressemblent souvent
à leur livrees c'est d'une profonde
vulgarité faisant ici référ au propos de
l'ancienne ministre sur la dérive
droitière de son parti durant la
campagne présidentielle détenenstion
alors que la lutte pour la présidence de
l'UMP se poursuit François Fillon
Jean-François Copé sont pour l'instant
candidats la fibre optique à
Saint-Quentin un dossier finalement plus
compliqué que prévu qu'entiope la régie
publique chargée de la déployer dans
l'agglomération cesse son activité à
destination du public c'est ce que nous
allons voir avec vous y mabuf bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la
Régie fibre optique quentiope également
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin tout
d'abord Maxime pour bien préciser la
fibre optique c'est quoi à quoi ça sert
un fibreoptique c'est un petit peu
difficile à imaginer surtout quand on
l'a pas encore alors il faut imaginer un
ensemble de brin fins et souple comme
comme un cheveux chaque brin véhicule un
signal lumineux et donc à travers ce
signal lumineux de l'information grâce à
la fibre on peut atteindre en théorie
plusieurs gig de débit en réalité dans
le commerce pour l'instant ce sont des
offres jusqu'à 100 m euh qui sont
proposés et une réalité encore plus
profonde quand on est sur le terrain en
réalité on atteint entre 20 à 40 50 m en
fonction de de l'endroit où on se trouve
en fonction de la distance par rapport
aux répartiteurs par rapport aux
armoires en fait qui contiennent cette
cette fibre optique alors comptenu du
cût élevé du câblage en France l'État a
préféré se tourner dans un premier temps
vers les opérateurs privés qui ont
indiqué l'an passé leurs intentions en
déploiement sur toute la France dans les
ivelines oranges et SFR couvriront en
théorie 83 % du territoire le reste
étant pris en charge par le Département
seulement voilà à Saint-Quentin on acidé
on a décidé de faire autrement les
pouvoirs publics n'ont pas souhaité
attendre que le privé se décide à mettre
en marche la machine ils ont créé en
2009 si je me trompe pas monsieur
maschbuff une régie qui s'appelle
cantiop et donc après 2 million d'euros
et 4000 prises installées la régie
arrête d'opérer pour les particuliers
les opérateurs privés ayant décidé de
s'installer sur le territoire alors
Monsieur maschbuff concrètement à quoi
devait servir cette régie à la base pour
que les spectateurs comprennent bien
alors tout d'abord cette régie elle a
comme objectif de répondre au souhait
des élus de l'agglomération de pouvoir
ne pas attendre que les opérateurs
déploient à leur rythme et de répondre
aux besoins de notre territoire qui est
atypique 50 ansine est une population
jeune avec des besoins en numérique
extrêmement important et lorsqu'elle a
été créée en 89 aucune réglementation
n'existait cette réglementation s'est
mis petit à petit en place elle a été à
peu près stabilisé au début de l'année
2012 et dans ce cadre là la Régie a
lancé ce qu'on appelle un appel à
coinvestissement auprès des opérateurs
puisque c'est la démarche aujourd'hui
dans la réglementation qu'il faut faire
et on a eu une grande surprise c'est de
voir qu'aucun opérateur ne souhaitait
venir déployer en indiquant concrètement
qu'il déploiererait à son rythme avec
son propre réseau dans un délai qui ne
correspond plus du tout à ce que nous on
souhaitait c'est sur 2 ans mais allant
jusqu'à 8 ans pour certaines communes et
certains endroits voilà aujourd'hui euh
la situation dans lequelle on se trouve
est inacceptable h tout d'abord une
situation qui ne peut pas
permettre de pouvoir déployer un réseau
puisque ces opérateurs nous annoncent
qu'il ne viendront pas sur notre réseau
donc on pas faire un réseau à sans
opérateurs ou que des petits opérateurs
donc il y a aujourd'hui un vide dans la
réglementation il y a aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'état aussi une situation qui
n'est pas acceptable puisque nous avons
une situation où l'État lui-même dit aux
opérateurs vous avez-vous la priorité à
ce niveau-là balayant d'un coup de
revers toutes les initiatives publiques
tous les réseaux d'initiatives publiques
qui sont sur le le territoire français
il y a pas que nous qui sommes concernés
et laissant comme ça la par belle aux
opérateurs et leur laissant à leur
rythme parce qu'aujourd'hui les
intentions aujourd'hui des opérateurs ne
sont que des intentions ça veut dire que
qui a été créé par qutiop le début de de
câblage qui a été réalisé sur
l'agglomération de 50 ans sur les SEP
communes ne va servir finalement à rien
si il servira d'abord je faut rappeler
que ce
câblage dans son architecture
horizontale est un câblage qui va
concerner l'ensemble je dirais du réseau
vous vous l'avez dit vous-même ce réseau
continuera à fonctionner pour les
entreprises mais aussi pour les
Collectiv locales qui progressivement
prennent des contrats avec qutiop je
vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui 450
entreprises sont déjà éligibles à la
fibre via qutiop à la fin de l'année
début de l'année prochaine 2000
reviendront rejoindre les entreprises
existantes donc l'architecture
aujourd'hui du réseau elle elle elle
restera elle est utile il n'y a pas de
ce côté-là de souci il y a un problème
c'est aujourd'hui de voir des opérateurs
qui ont fait un choix de ne pas profiter
je dirais de la dynamique d'une
collectivité de vouloir en fin de compte
ensemble on veut pas aller faire notre
propre réseau contre un tel ou un tel
mais on veut ensemble essayer d'aller
plus vite et de répondre le plus vite
possible au besoins donc là les
opérateurs veulent développer un réseau
un réseau parallèle c'estcoutez les
interrogé moi aujourd'hui tout ce que je
peux comprendre c'est que nous avons
fait un appel à cofinancement c'est une
opération qui nécessite de mois de dél
nous avons c'est ça le 15 mai le
pratiquement le non c'est ça le 15 mars
15 mai nous n'avions aucune réponse
malgré les contacts qu'on avait eu avec
les deux grands opérateurs qui
aujourd'hui sont dans la dynamique de
déploiement en France et automatiquement
on a eu un constat et une confirmation
dernièrement de voir certains opérateurs
nous dire qu'il n viendront pas sur ce
réseau donc il y a quand même une
situation d'otage qui est assez
inacceptable aujourd'hui une
collectivité fait un choix elle fait un
choix d'accompagner concrètement ce
développement en mettant de l'argent sur
la table et aujourd'hui pour des raisons
certainement je dirais l'entreprise ces
entreprisesl font un choix de ne pas
répondre à à cet accompagnement et et de
partir concrètement à leur rythme qui
n'est pas du tout celui que qutiop
propose on va parler justement des
conséquences tout à l'heure pour les
usagers qui attendent justement la fibre
alors on l'a dit en préambule la plupart
des communes ont choisi de passer par le
département ou des opérateurs privés il
y a eu des tests qui ont été faits
notamment à Chatou à montaesson les
déploiements qu'on appelle les
déploiements opérationnels ont commencé
sur la commune de moropa une commune
proche de de de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
nous sommes en ligne avec George BF
bonsoir bonsoir donc vous êtes adjoint
au maire délégé aux travaux sur la
commune de morepa où est-ce qu'on en est
de de la couverture de la commune au
niveau fibre
optique alors le déploiement à le
déploiement opérationnel a commencé
depuis maintenant 8 mois à peu près euh
donc la la commune de mourpa a été letie
en en C il y a cinq ls qui ont été
identif
le premier lot est en cours de
déploiement actuellement et les les
premiers abonnés devraent être accordés
d'ici la fin de l'année alors du coup on
prévoit une couverture totale pour pour
quand alors l'opérateur s'est engagé à
raccorder l'ensemble des abonnés sur un
délai de 5 ans maximum alors sachant que
le le premier do donc celui qui va qui
est en cours de déploiement actuellement
va couvrir à peu près 35 % de la
population on on passera les 50 ou 55 %
à la fin de l'année prochaine ch et
après le reste se fera sur encore sur un
délai de 3 ans ça sera un petit peu plus
un petit peu plus long parce que c'est
principalement des zones pavillonnaire
comment vous expliquez une une telle
rapidité c'estàd qu'il y a une il y a
des opérations de de lobbing je le dis
clairement du côté de de mon repas enfin
comment comment ça se passe exactement
pour faire venir la fibre optique dans
sa
commune alors nous à notre à notre
niveau ce qui avait été engagé au niveau
de la commune on avait fait des on avait
fait des études il y a quelques années
déjà euh justement pour on avait imaginé
un certain nombre de un certain nombre
de de scénarios possibles dont comme a
fait 51 mil la possibilité de
d'implanter notre propre réseau et puis
de faire venir un opérateur euh ce que
nous ce que nous avait freiné à l'époque
c'était le coût le coût je vais dire
exorbitant de de cette opération là puce
que çaissait de plusieurs millions
d'euros et donc cé un petit peu
difficile on avait regardé différentes
solutions et dans les dans les travaux
d'approche on était allé voir aussi les
opérateurs de enfin de fibre optique
alors à l'époque les lois étaient pas
encore complètement finalisées on savait
pas trop on savait pas trop dans dans
quelle direction on se on se on allait
par contre on avait cette volonté
justement de de de faire en sorte que
que comment dire que ENF que ça évite
quoi et et ça ne coûte rien à la commune
juste pour conclure aujourd'hui ça ne
coûte rien ce dispositif sur place
oui alors donc orange a décidé de de
venir sur la commune de morpa et prend
prend à sa charge la totalité des des
travaux des travaux de dépement merci
George bief d'avoir été en ligne avec
nous donc adjoint au maire de morpa
chargé du projet du très haut débit Yve
mchbuf quand vous entendez l'exemple de
morpa ça ne coûte rien à la commune ils
n'ont pas fait le choix d'investir dans
un câblage de réseau parce que ça
coûtait cher vous regrettez pas le choix
aujourd'hui de qutiop non parce queon a
une typologie d'habitat et une situation
géographique qui est très différente de
MPa
50 ansvin c'est la composition de SEP
communes avec des compositions
géographiques et des compositions
d'habitat très différentes si vous
prenez le cas de Manamo
ou ou de cas même de sur les secteurs
des lancours on a une situation je
dirais de de de très rurale et donc on
sait qu'aujourd'hui des opérateurs sur
ces zonesl ils iront peut-être jamais ou
ils iront très difficilement c'était le
rôle des pouvoirs publics oui al sachant
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le choix que
nous on a fait on voit bien à morp il y
a un qui de de de partir tant mieux je
veux dire aujourd'hui on aura des déjà
des départs aussi de fibre sur aancour
parce qu'on a sur aancours aiguill en
cours des zones dit très dense et orange
a annoncé concrètement des opérations
dans le cours de l'année 2013 pour faire
quelques poches de qui représent à peu
près 10 ou 12 % de la population dans
chaque commune donc ces démarch là
arrive et tant mieux je veux dire moi j
vois pas combien suf le problème qu'on a
sa-quentin c'est que on ne peut pas
attendre je dirait des des délais aussi
long sachez qu'aujourd'hui on annonce la
fin de de trappe en 2009 2019 pardon
2020 je veux dire enfin moi je veux bien
mais je pense pas que les habitants
attendent des délais aussi long il y a
on a un besoin aujourd'hui en France de
de de ce réseau on a une collectivité
qui se prend en charge pour contribuer
pour dynamiser ce territoire parce que
ça correspond une dynamique voilà on a
alors vous savez aujourd'hui on a une
situation mais j'espère bien qu'elle va
changer vous imaginez bien
qu'aujourd'hui le conseil
d'administration de la Régie
fibreoptique que je préside ne ne lâche
pas prise quand vous disiez qutiope
arrête non qutiope auourdhi suspend le
le déploiement sur la fibre aux
habitants en continuant le le reste
pourquoi on dit on suspend c'est
qu'aujourd'hui mon travail le travail de
la du conseil d'administration c'est
avant tout maintenant de solliciter les
pouvoirs publics à commencé par la
ministre à commencé par le chef de
l'État je siège dans une association
nationale qui couvre tous les besoins du
du qui s'appelle la Vica bah cette
association qui couvre qui regroupe tous
les les élus de France de tout bord
politique vientent interpeller le
président de la République et entre
autres il y a une des questions qui qui
qui concerne en plein cœur SaintQuentin
nieline concernant justement la
possibilité à des territoires comme
Saint-Quentin qui déploie un réseau
d'initiative publique bah de pouvoir le
faire sur sur sa zone et et que en fin
de compte on n pas un système qui font
que derrière on privilégie en fin de
compte des opérateurs et on empêche
concrètement les élus de faire leur
travail sur le territoire fa que l'État
oblige oblige ces sociétés à travailler
orang et à travailler l'État a fait un
appel à ce qu'on appelle les zone amis
pourer et puis concrètement dans ces
zones sur lesquelles on s'est positionné
aussi c'estàdire que qu s'est positionné
l'état fait un choix après de longues
relances de ne solliciter que les
opérateurs sans faire de publicité les
opérateurs connus après de longues
relances auprès du conse général à
l'investissement j'attends toujours la
réponse il y a aussi un abus un excès
aujourd'hui des pouvoirs publics qui en
fin de compte font le lit des opérateurs
je pense on va faire juste une petite
pause pour ceux qui viennent de nous
rejoindre nous parlons ce soir du très
bit plus particulièrement à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline où la régie en
charge de son déploiement a décidé de
suspendre ses activités à destination du
public petit résumé avec ce reportage
cantiop stop et net c'est l'annonce
faite vendredi par la régie publique
jusque là chargée de déployer la fibre
optique sur 501 en yeline conséquence
les deux principaux opérateurs privés
ont désormais le champ libre
conformément à la législation dès
l'instant qu'un opérateur privé fait
part de sa volonté d'installer le très
haut débit sur un territoire l'opérateur
public déjà en place doit proposer un
cofinancement selon cantiop tous les
opérateurs privés auraient refusé de
coffinancer le projet menaçant même de
déployer un réseau privé parallèlement
au réseau public ce qui va à l'encontre
de l'objectif de base de la régie
publique je crois que les le le le corps
politique à Saint-Quentin ne voulait pas
recommencer le même schéma que quand il
y avait Numéricable quand il y avait les
opérateurs privés qui décide de quel
quartier on fait à quel rythme on y va
queles sont les les différentes
possibilités aujourd'hui la volonté
c'est de pouvoir apporter à tout le
monde un service et que ce soit sur
l'ensemble du territoire faire une
péréquation que les quartiers un peu
plus chers à construire parce que ce
sont des zones beaucoup plus rurales ne
soient pas pénalisé de ce faitl et que
les quartiers plus denses soient
favorisés les deux grands opérateurs
devrait avoir couvert d'ici 2020 83 %
des Yvelines le reste étant assuré par
le conseil général à titre d'exemple
grâce à cet accord 35 % des habitants de
morepa ville moyenne mendance auront
accès à la fibre d'ici la fin de l'année
une révolution pour un territoire qui
souffre d'un bas débit ce qu'on appelle
le déploiement horizontal est terminé
c'est-à-dire que les adductions de fibre
optique du centre-ville sont finies les
armoires du centre-ville viennent d'être
posées et orange commence le déploiement
Horizont ce qu'on appelle pardon le
déploiement vertical c'est-à-dire
commence à raccorder les immeubles selon
la mairie d'ici fin 2013 plus de la
moitié de la ville sera couverte
quandtiop poursuit son déploiement
auprès des entreprises jusqu'à présent 2
millions d'euros ont été investis pour
4000 prises installées sur la communauté
d'agglomération la régie publique a fait
parvenir un courrier à la ministre
délégué chargé de l'économie numérique
pour l'interpeller sur les problèmes
qu'elle rencontrent de son côté orange
attend d'avoir échangé avec Antiope pour
se positionner de que soit justement
monsieur mabuf par rapport à cet échange
avec Orange où est-ce qu'on en est
actuellement depuis qu'on a fait ce
sujet écoutez dans le cadre de du
dialogue qu'on a lancé déjà depuis
plusieurs mois parce qu'on a sur le
ccissement naturellement préparé le
terrain des des la fin de l'année
dernière moi j'ai participé moi-même à
des réunions avec plutôt des technicien
de et puis par les grands patrons hein
de d'orange euh je dirais il y avait un
intérêt commun après derrière il une
décision je pense nationale qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la réponse elle est nette
j'ai eu le président de l'agglomération
qui a reçu une net aujourd'hui Lu
indiquant le refus de orangange de venir
coinvestir sur le réseau public de de
Saint-Quentin concrètement comment vous
avez l'impression d'être perçu par
justement des des grands opérateurs
comme ça quand vous vous arrivez petite
régie qutiope il y a il y a un vrai
dialogue qui s ou alors c'est vim c'est
que on estê ressenti comme des gneur
certainement dans dans dans dans la
politique privée de ces opérateurs alors
que on est on se situe nous plutôt pour
venir en complément pour aller plus vite
je veux dire un opérateur qui viendrait
sur le réseau maintenant aurait un
retour sur investissement qui se ferait
beaucoup plus rapidement voilà mais la
démarche aujourd'hui de range telle
qu'elle est sur SaintQuentin elle est
pas unique j'ai d'autres collègues en
province puisque comme à la Vic je
côtois quand même beaucoup d'élus qui
sont dans une situation identique avec
des problèmes identiques donc je crois
que la la position elle est pas locale
elle est nationale alors la fibre c'est
très bien maintenant faut savoir ce
qu'on fait avec la fibre si la fibre
arrive vous parliez tout à l'heure des
attentes du bassin de la population nous
sommes allés demander justement à
quelques cinquantinois ce qu'ils
attendaient est-ce qu'ils attendaient
cette fibre optique avec impatience euh
non je suis pas du tout satisfait pas du
tout pourquoi parce queelle est sur
ADSL donc vous attendez le haut débit
ouais ou ouais moi ça me suffit euh pour
l'instant ça va j'ai pas de problème
particulier avec le le haut débit le
petit débit tout tout fonctionne très
bien oui ouais ouais je suis satisfait
pas complètement non euh parce que très
souvent euh ça coupe et euh non je suis
pas satisfaite on a le 512 K minimum et
et donc moi j'attends avec impatience
justement vous tombez bien pour avoir
beaucoup mieux
au débit normalement je l'ai déjà mais
j'ai le le plus bas débit du Haut Débit
hein donc et bah je sais pas là
normalement c'est on peut on peut
expirer avec la fibre optique mais 2020
donc voilà donc on est vraiment les
Oubliés là j'habite Romainville à
Manille hameau et le le hameau de
Romainville et vraiment c'est une
honte parlait tout à l'heure des poches
de population qui n'ont pas accès à
Internet on parle d'un débit de 512 K
avec la dernière personne qu'on a pu
rencontrer donc ça va plutôt dans votre
votre sens vous êtes plutôt content de
voir qu'il y a une attente que ce que
vous aviez prévu répond aux attentes de
la population maintenant il faut comme
on le disait content concrètement que
les gens soient pas contents non je veux
dire on est d'accord tout qui vous appu
au moins mais attendez je suis un élu
donc je suis quelqu'un de la population
donc je dirais ce que disaient les les
personnes je le vis je le vis au
quotidien avec aujourd'hui on le
sait une montée en puissance aujourd'hui
de ce qu'on appelle du besoin en bande
passante des utilisateurs et si fait
qu'on sait que la situation elle se
dégradera au fil des des jours à la
limite on peut tenir encore 6 mois un an
mais demain je veux dire quand le les
services qui vont être offerts vont
prendre de plus en plus de demande
passant la situation sera catastrophique
est-ce qu'on doit attendre dans
certaines communes de l'agglomération
des délais de 9 ans où là les gens
pourront pas accéder au service non on
est dans une situation qui est pas
acceptable donc dans l'état actuel des
choses 2020 sauf si changement sauf si
les grands opérateurs se tournent vers
vous pour permettre un câblage plus
rapide plus plus rapide effectivement
donc de des différentes populations sur
50 ans en yeline une toute dernière
question ceux qui sont déjà raccordés je
pense au particulierers on s'est
concentré sur les particuliers il y a
aussi tout le volet entreprise qui lui
se se poursuit pour qutiup mais pour les
particuliers qui sont déjà raccordés qui
ont déjà fait des travaux chez eux qui
ont eu les techniciens qui sont venus
qui ont installé ses boîtiers pour la
fibre ça va servir à quoi alors déjà je
vous rappelais sur la la partie
horizontale ce réseau aujourd'hui
utilisé non pas que pour eux aujourd'hui
ils peuvent avoir un un opérateur hein
de très haut débit puisque il y a plein
de petits opérateurs qui aujourd'hui
proposent des services c'est vrai que le
le français il est attaché à des
opérateurs qu'il a déjà aujourd'hui et
donc il chercheent aussi à avoir la
possibilité d'avoir des gros opérateurs
on pourrait déployer un réseau
aujourd'hui sont les grands opérateurs
je veux dire mais on sait bien que on
répond pas là au besoins globals des
habitants j'espère bien 2020 qu'on va
pas attendre 2020 j'espère bien que là
les interventions qu'on fait au niveau
du ministre du numérique au niveau de
l'État au niveau du président de la
République au niveau de l'arcepep au
niveau du commissariat général
àinvestissement vont aboutir et queon va
enfin avoir quelque chose qui va
permettre au réseau d'initiative
publique de pouvoir se mettre en place
et de jouer leur rôle sur un territoire
où on en a pas besoin le président de la
République l'ancien comme le futur le
nouveau par pardon on on on donnit des
orientations pour que la France soit un
pays exemplaire dans ce cadre là
laissons aidons les les les
collectivités locales les les réseaux
d'initiativ publi à se mettre en place
quand tu payant suspendu ces activités à
destination des particuliers ce qui
avait été signé avec les copropriétés
pour l'installation de la fibre c'est
suspendu également les travaux n'auront
pas lieu bah pour l'instant on attendait
concrètement pour vous savez pour faire
un déploiement c'est le fameux
coinvestissement après on dci les zones
par zone et donc dans tous les endroits
où les les copropriétés avaient signé
convention ben je veux dire on était
prêt à y aller mais c'est
ah ben aujourd'hui on en attente moi
j'espère que d'ici la fin de l'année on
aura des réponses qui nous permettront
de pouvoir redémarrer hein le stop hein
ça se respecte pendant un certain temps
et après derrière on peut passer le stop
j'espère qu'on aura des solutions en
tout cas compte sur moi compte sur le
conseil d'administration de la rég fibre
optique pour que on aille voir les
décideurs ceux qui je veux dire
aujourd'hui donnent des orientations
pour que on puisse avoir la possibilité
de déployer un réseau d'initiativ
publiqu sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin et on fera un point
complet bien sûr à la rentrée voir si
les choses VT avancé mercib merci Maxim
également peut-être venu nous éclairer
sur ce sujet de la fibre optique dans le
reste de l'actualité du jour une
mobilisation d'amnestie internationale
une marche de la liberté était organiser
une opération qui a permis de
sensibiliser aux actions menées depuis
déjà 50 ans reportage de Catherine
zulato et puis on se retrouve ensuite
sur ce plateau pour la page sport évoqué
notamment les gios de
Londres Lucienne kelc est bénévole
artisan du monde elle est venue
participer à une marche annuelle
proposée par le groupe local d'amnestie
internationale tout naturellement faut
faire évoluer la
société c'est très difficile de faire
respecter les droits les droits de
l'homme dans dans le monde entier y
compris en France cette marche de la
liberté pour sensibiliser aux actions de
leur groupe local est organisé depuis
les années 2005 avec leur t-shirt jaune
et noir les militants veulent faire
connaître leur mouvement et offrir d'
style une meilleure lésibilité les gens
nous posent des questions que que font
des des militants des droits de l'homme
à travers à travers no campagne à
travers nos villes et se baladant et
bien nous leur proposons
de de mener des actions avec nous tels
que
les pétitions et parmi les pétitions que
les marcheurs pouvaient signer il y
avait celle concernant deux jeunes
filles mexicaines qui auraient subi des
violences physiques dans leur pays dans
ce pays les autorités ont toujours sont
très puissantes et les forces de
sécurité mène une campagne souvent de de
de violation des droits humains
d'autres actions sont programmées le 8
septembre le groupe cquantinois
participera à un festival à MPa et
présentera une exposition concernant 12
personnes en danger dans le monde
l'antenne locale compte 12 membres
actifs et 150 adhérents et
sympathisants